we're given two different complex
numbers here and we want to figure out
what is the product pause this video and
see if you can figure that out
all right now let's work on this
together
so we know from the form that it's
written here that the modulus of w sub 1
is equal to 3 and we know that the
argument of w sub 1 is equal to 330
degrees
and by the same line of reasoning we
know that the modulus of w sub 2 is
equal to 2
and that the argument of w sub 2
is going to be equal to we can see that
right over here
120 degrees
now when you multiply complex numbers
you could view as one transforming the
other we've seen this in multiple
examples so let's imagine that we are
transforming w2 by multiplying it by w1
so what is going to happen
well let me write it here so what's the
resulting modulus of w1 times w2 well
we're just going to scale up w2's
modulus by w1's modulus or essentially
we're just going to multiply the two so
this is going to be equal to 6 3 times 2
and then the argument
of w sub 1 times w sub 2. if we start at
w sub 2's argument 120 degrees and then
we rotate it by w sub 1's argument well
then you're going to add these two
angles that gets you to
450 degrees so this is equal to 450
degrees which is more than a complete
rotation and so if we wanted to give it
an angle between 0 and 360 degrees if we
just subtract 360 from that that is
going to be equal to
90 degrees
and so we can rewrite this here or we
can rewrite the product as w sub 1 times
w sub 2 is equal to
its modulus 6
times cosine of its argument
90 degrees plus i
times sine
of its argument
now we know what the cosine and sine of
90 degrees is cosine of 90 degrees is
equal to 0 and sine of 90 degrees is
equal to 1. so all of this simplifies
quite nicely all you're left with is a 6
times i
so this is equal to 6
i
and we are done